how's it going everybody it's Morin and
I just want to start this off by saying
thank you all so much for 400,000
subscribers I never thought that I would
be here today and have this much support
from the community and I just want to
thank you all so much from the bottom of
my heart it means the world to me I'm so
glad you all enjoy my videos and of
course I'm going to do everything I can
to continue to keep you up to date on
everything happening with the Marvel
Universe so we have three giveaway
winners to announce and just so you all
are aware I don't handpick these winners
they are all picked completely at random
by a YouTube program that I use which I
will show you all on screen and if you
did not win this giveaway of course I'll
be starting a new giveaway right away
when I hit 450,000 subscribers I'll be
doing the same giveaway and then when I
hit 500,000 subscribers half a million
I'll be doing a massive giveaway that
I'll announce later on I'll also be
doing some giveaways on my Instagram and
Twitter so if you'd like you all can
follow me on there as well okay so now
time for the giveaway remember that the
program picks a user completely at
random and the first winner for the
giveaway is YouTube at user apple juice
and the next winner of the giveaway is
YouTube user Karen Naidu sorry I
probably butchered your name but you won
and the third and final winner for the
giveaway is youtube user DN productions
Congrats to the winners you will get to
choose one item from the Marvel Legends
series collection and for the rest of
you like I said I am starting another
giveaway right now at the 450,000
subscriber mark I will be picking three
winners again and each will get to
choose one item from the Marvel Legends
series collection and then at the
500,000 subscriber mark I will be doing
a massive giveaway that I will announce
a little bit later on so be sure to stay
sub to my channel and keep liking and
commenting on the videos for your chance
to win the next giveaway and of course
so you can stay up to date on everything
relating to Marvel so as always thank
you all so much for watching and again
thank you all so much for your support
and 400,000 subscribers couldn't have
done this without you all and I
sincerely appreciate it as always thank
you all so much for watching
or for
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby now
your